usa la fórmula cuadrática para resolver
la ecuación 0 es igual a menos 7 q
cuadrada más 29 y bueno la fórmula
cuadrática nos sirve para solucionar
ecuaciones de la forma a x cuadrada más
bx más e igual a cero o en su dado caso
cero igual a equis cuadrada más bx más
aa equis cuadrada más bx más c y esta es
la ecuación cuadrática general en la
cual casi siempre se usa la variable x
para resolverla pero también podemos
usar cualquier otra letra de hecho en
esta ocasión va a usar q y aunque de una
manera muy general las soluciones se
expresan en términos de x también la
fórmula cuadrática nos dice que las
soluciones se ven de la siguiente manera
x es igual a menos ven más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 hace todo
esto dividido entre 2 a todo esto entre
2 am y estas son las soluciones de la
ecuación cuadrática usando la fórmula
pero bueno todo esto está expresado en
la variable x date cuenta que en esta
ocasión las soluciones de esta ecuación
cuadrática dependen de q lo podremos
poner x pero también q nos sirve y por
lo tanto voy a decir que este el
coeficiente que está al lado del término
que está elevado al cuadrado este de
aquí va a ser am este de aquí es am
este es el término que está al lado de
la q elevada a la primera potencia a
este le voy a decir que sven es el que
está al lado de la primera potencia y
por último este que es el coeficiente
constante a este le voy a llamarse este
de aquí va a ser cero y entonces lo
único que hay que hacer es aplicar esta
fórmula cuadrática para kun y que nos va
a quedar bueno vamos a decir que q es
igual a menos b pero ve en esta ocasión
vale 2 entonces menos 2 más menos +
menos la raíz cuadrada esta fórmula
sería muy buena que le aprendieras debe
cuadrada es decir de 2 elevado al
cuadrado menos 4 veces hace menos cuatro
veces a pero a vale menos 7 entonces
unos 4 veces menos 7 x sé pero se vale 9
por lo tanto a esto hay que
multiplicarlo por lo que vale c
ya todo esto a todo esto de aquí hay que
dividirlo entre dos veces pero a vale de
menos siete entonces todo esto entre dos
por menos 7
y bueno lo que hay que hacer es resolver
esta ecuación y que me va a quedar esto
es igual a menos 2
más menos la raíz cuadrada de pie 2 al
cuadrado es 4 y después me queda menos
por menos me da más por más me da más
más 7 por 4 28 por 9 cuanto es 28 por 9
vamos a hacerlo aquí 28 lo voy a
multiplicar por nueve y dice 9 por 8 72
y llevamos 79 por 218 más 7 25
252 perfecto pongámoslo aquí más 252 ya
todo esto todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre dos por menos 7 lo cual me da
menos 14 y bueno pues vamos a sumar 2
los números que están adentro de la raíz
y me queda que esto es igual a menos dos
más menos la raíz cuadrada de 4 252 lo
cual me da 256 ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre menos 14 muy bien pero cuánto es
la raíz cuadrada de 256 bueno pues la
raíz cuadrada de 256 es 16 todo esto se
va a 16 puedes tú calcularlo 16 al
cuadrado es 256 por lo tanto vamos a
sustituirlo pero aquí hay un paso muy
importante te das cuenta que tengo más o
menos la raíz cuadrada de 256 esto
quiere decir que tengo dos posibles
soluciones la primera solución se vería
algo así menos 2
+ 16 / menos 14 me estoy tomando el
primer signo que es el signo de más o en
su dado caso la otra solución se puede
ver como menos dos menos 16 entre menos
14 y esto es muy importante porque
estamos tomando todos soluciones este
signo de más me está marcando este más
que yo tengo aquí y por otra parte este
menos que está aquí es justo este mismo
menos que estoy poniendo aquí la
solución se divide en dos en una
solución con signo positivo y de otra
solución con signo negativo y pues
cuánto es esto bueno pues entonces va a
ser igual a menos 2 16 me da 14 positivo
14 entre 14 negativo meta - 1 esta es mi
primer solución la otra solución es la
siguiente - 2 - 16 esto es lo mismo que
menos 18 entre menos 14 y cuánto es esto
menos 18 lo puedo sacar mitad y me da 9
y darte cuenta que menos entre menos se
van menos entre menos es más
y después 14 le puede sacar mitad y me
dan 7 por lo tanto en nuestra solución
son 9 séptimos y ya tengo mis dos raíces
para esta ecuación cuadrática mis dos
valores de q que cumplen que al ponerse
en esta ecuación cuadrática me dan de
solución igual a cero son mis soluciones
de esta ecuación cuadrática utilizando
la fórmula cuadrática y de hecho lo
podemos comprobar si ponemos este valor
y lo sustituimos aquí en el valor de q y
ponemos este valor después y sus tribus
y los sustituimos aquí también en este
valor de q nos tiene que dar 0 y además
vamos hacerlo para el primero para que
veas que en efecto nos sale este
resultado si yo pusiera menos uno me
quedaría menos 7 que multiplica a menos
1 elevado al cuadrado más 2 que subes
multiplica menos uno más 9 y cuánto es
esto pues bueno menos 1 elevado al
cuadrado pues esto es lo mismo que uno
menos 7 por 1 me da menos 72 por menos
uno me da menos 2 menos 7 menos 2 me da
menos 9 más 9 me da 0 y de hecho se te
queda de tarea y sería muy bueno que tú
y también 9 séptimos es la otra raíz de
esta ecuación cuadrática